pour voir pour le croire mais vraiment
ginette la verrière a perdu ce qu'elle
appelle son coin de paradis
la maison voisine à la sienne dans le
vieux terrebonne a été rachetée l'an
dernier par un promoteur immobilier qui
a entrepris de l'agrandir jusqu'aux
limites de son terrain et travaux
conforme à la réglementation municipale
qui ne prévoit pas de marge minimale
madame la verrière admet avoir signé un
formulaire où elle confirme avoir pris
connaissance des détails du projet de
construction wilane et ne pas s'y
opposer
elle le regrette aujourd'hui à tous les
matins la chaire recommence
j'ouvre le rideau de ma chambre j'étais
encore là dedans je dessers bourges dans
tout le temps ça peut être beau jeu
c'est pour quoi faire
c'est au bout de la ligne comme obligés
d'endurer sol l'eau tout ce qu'elle a
fait mais jour le même promoteur obtenu
le mois dernier une dérogation de la
ville pour construire un bâtiment
moderne sur la rue les plus pittoresques
du quartier ici avant il y avait deux
restaurants le moisi mme une
chocolatière est elle aussi dépité pour
nos clients le soleil la scéno mais
c'est juste d'avoir c'est de l'argent
circule ça va être un bâtiment une autre
dynamique on va essayer de faire avec
on n'a pas le choix et c'est ce que la
ville nous impose amélie villeneuve fait
partie d'un groupe de citoyens de
commerçants inquiets pour l'avenir du
quartier
fourmies récemment ce groupe demande à
la municipalité de faire plus d'efforts
pour préserver le caractère patrimonial
du vieux terrebonne
nous ce qu'on espère dans le fond c'est
que dans 5 ans 10 ans 25 ans se soit
encore agréable de vivre dans le vieux
terrebonne et de visiter le vieux
terrebonne et là l'inquiétude qui
apparaît c'est que si on vient ici pour
visiter finalement un quartier composé
de tours à condos
c'est beaucoup moins intéressant ces
citoyens ont pris la parole mercredi
soir lors d'une consultation publique
sur la révision du règlement du tournage
du quartier la ville at elle des
pressions des promoteurs pour créer des
ongles qui permet la construction de
quatre étages
dans le vieux terrebonne l'absence du
maire marc andré plante a été remarquée
il a également décliné notre demande
d'entrevue au maire et wallons c'est
pourquoi le représentant son équipe a
tenté de se faire rassurant le lien ici
dans ce projet règlement ne vient
bouleverser l'adn du vieux terrebonne le
directeur de l'urbanisme a toutefois
reconnu que le quartier faisait l'objet
de nombreuses convoitises
on a effectivement beaucoup de
constructeurs qui sont attirés par le
vieux terrebonne et ils viennent oui
effectivement nous défier de façon
continuelle en déposant des dossiers en
l'isolant devant le comité
cette propriété ancestrale par exemple
est à vendre pour 1 million 200 mille
dollars
sur internet on précise qu il serait
également possible d'acheter le terrain
voisin pour y construire des triplex et
des maisons de prestige à trois étages à
vendre également pour entrepreneurs
seulement cette superbe maison
construite en 1823 derrière laquelle il
serait possible précise-t-on le
construire trois unités de logements en
plein coeur du vieux terrebonne le
conseiller du district andré fontaine
est préoccupé par toute cette frénésie
oui la densification on comprend que son
emprunt mais dans le secteur historique
du quartier
on peut pas faire de densification à
outrance sans tenir compte du facteur
patrimoniale du facteur humain du
secteur agrément talent cela dit il
arrive selon lui que certains projets
audacieux réussisse là où d'autres ont
échoué
les corps vieux terrebonne par exemple
ont été encensés par tous elle
prestigieux magazine d'architecturé son
promoteur philippe lemieux qui développe
plusieurs projets dans le quartier ça
prend du courage faire des affaires dans
le vieux terrebonne pour développer pour
rénover ou encore pour construire un
neuf
un édifice les pressions
social du quartier des citoyens moi je
demeure ici mes enfants vont à l'école
de quartier je marche le soir dans le
quartier
donc je m'assure que ce que je fais et
ce soit respectueux de mes concitoyens
le mes voisins le vieux terrebonne
c'est aussi et surtout les des moulins
inscrits au registre du patrimoine
culturel du québec tout comme la maison
bélisle qui date d'avant la conquête ce
statut les protège quant aux autres
bâtiments caractère patrimonial du vieux
terrebonne
la ville assure que le nouveau règlement
de zonage reflétera l'âme et l'esprit du
quartier les citoyens jugeront plusieurs
d'entre eux souhaitent surtout qui te
permettent d'éviter les dérives
immobilières appréhender j'espère que
les démarches qui se font au nord vont
aider les autres ici jérôme l'abbé
radio-canada terrebonne